hey guys my name is Jess McDonald today
it is the ninth of September and you're
tuned into gamespot knees the game may
still be another two months away from
launch but the industry being what it is
Bethesda are already talking about DLC
plans for fall out for the DLC will run
you thirty dollars for the season pass
which Bethesda of sad will give you
access to quote all the fallout 4 DLC we
ever do good work on that one Bethesda
that is exactly what a season pass
always means unless you're talking about
borderlands it gets a little weirder
though because while the path has a
price tags that Deb actually don't have
any content in mind at this stage they
explain since we're still hard at work
on the game we don't know what the
actual DLC will be yet but it will start
coming early next year based on what we
did for oblivion fallout 3 and Skyrim we
know that it will be worth at least 40
bucks and if we do more you'll get it
all with the season pass both fallout 3
and fallout new vegas got five paid DLC
expansions each which came with new
quests items and achievements so that's
probably what we can expect Bethesda are
also promising regular free updates
which freestyle today was apple
announcement day and so you don't have
to dig around the internet to find out
what happened I've got all the important
bits first up the iphone 6s and 6s plus
were announced both phones feature 3d
touch which is a touch screen feature
that recognizes force they both feature
the new 64-bit a 9 chip a 12 megapixel
iSight camera which can record in 4k and
they come in for fancy colors in the US
the phones range from one hundred and
ninety-nine bucks for the 16 gigabyte 6f
to four hundred and ninety-nine dollars
for the 128 gigabyte 6s plus iOS 9 will
officially launch on sep tember 16 apple
also showed off the enterprise focused
ipad whoa that comes with a 12 point
nine inch screen and a 9x chip and will
offer a surface esque case
keyboard that's most interestingly
though is the new one hundred and fifty
dollar Apple TV aside from being a nap
focused media streamer its new remote is
touch voice and motion enabled which
makes it suitable for gaming Apple TV
versions of Guitar Hero live skylanders
and Disney infinity are coming to the
devices App Store as well as Crossy Road
and a new Harmonix developed game called
beat sports which looks to be a
collection of music infused minigames
the new Apple TV also has support for
third-party controllers and pc
accessories manufacturers steelseries
has announced its Nimbus game controller
for the device a new report has
indicated that Kingdom Hearts 2.9 could
be coming to ps3 and ps4 and I do
apologize for the fact that that's a
point one Kingdom Hearts away from the
game that you actually want to hear
about kingdom hearts fansite KH 13
uncovered a particularly interesting
part of the game developers resume on
linkedin CEO soccerbase Square Enix
developer lists that they previously
worked on Kingdom Hearts 2.9 for 10
months where they oversaw things like
game idea planning and documentation
next to the game name it lists the two
sony platforms that the game will
presumably arrive on the devs profile
also references their involvement in
Kingdom Hearts 3 let me know down in the
comments what you cared about today and
if you're keen on the new I things you
can add a gamespot oh we've got stories
on how much the witcher 3 cost to make
and issues with Destiny's new update
that is everything I have for you today
as always let me know what you thought
and i'll catch the same time tomorrow
you